(electronic music)
(slow, dramatic rock music)
- Day six.
Somewhere in Mississippi.
This hotel is horrible.
That drawer is just filled
with fingernail clippings.
While I was showering,
two cockroaches
ferried me the soap.
♪ Ain't there a prayer out there
♪ To save me
- This is the end.
Starting to feel a
little bit futile.
♪ Ain't there a prayer out there
♪ To save me
(slow, dramatic rock music)
- But I gotta job to do.
So fuck it.
Roustabout.
(fast heavy metal music)
(splashing)
(fast folk music)
- [Tomato Shorts] Mr. Minnow?
- [Li'l Minnow] Yes, sir.
- You're drawing your map?
- Yes, sir.
- Okay, what we're gonna do.
You're gonna ride down
this little waterway here
called the
Intercoastal Water Way.
And you're gonna come up
here to what they call
the Industrial Lock.
We come out of that lock,
we're gonna be on the
Mississippi again.
- That's where we're
landing in New Orleans.
- Yes.
- [Li'l Minnow] I
drew it to scale.
- [Tomato Shorts] That's
a really good picture.
- This is where it guys
nuts right in here.
- [Tomato Shorts] Yeah.
- This is just gonna be the
hardest stretch right here.
(laughing)
It's been seven straight
days of jet skiing,
I'm exhausted.
I'm chaffed.
I'm broken.
My balls are swollen.
(laughing)
We've only raised
$20,000 out of $50,000.
I'm starting to feel a
little bit like a failure.
But you know what?
Had to make it to New
Orleans that night
because I had a show to
do with my comedy partner,
Kristen Schaal,
(audience applauding)
and I'm not gonna
fuck that up, too.
New Orleans!
I'm coming for ya.
(intense rock music)
- Hey guy, you're
going the wrong way.
It's that way,
you piece of shit!
(intense rock music)
(jet ski engine roaring)
- Welcome to the
Gulf of New Mexico.
New Orleans is a city steeped
in culture and history.
Most of these ships out
here are mining ships
for novelty items for
Bachelorette Parties.
They're mostly penis
straws and the beads
they give women for
showing their tits.
First think I always do
when I get to New Orleans
is I hire one man to kill
another man for sport
and then I have an oyster.
Can't wait.
Falling apart infrastructure.
We must be close
to New Orleans now.
♪ Everybody's
coming to my house.
- Look at where the fuck we are?
We started in Chicago
motherfuckers!
Look at this!
Weeds and shit.
This is some New
Orleans weeds, man.
We're so close!
I can't wait!
- We're so close!
- Li'l Minnow, what's
been your favorite part
of the trip so far?
- The hotels!
♪ Everybody's coming to my house
- Nothing to see here.
♪ It's safe in here
(slow folk music)
♪ Alone at night
♪ You are hiding from the storm.
- Here's where we start
going from the natural beauty
of the Gulf into the industrial
wasteland of New Orleans.
I love New Orleans, but my God,
the Mississippi River,
right around New Orleans,
is just filled with
the weirdest shit.
♪ All alone
♪ You are right in front
- Holy shit.
(slow folk music)
(boat horn blowing)
Why would they build a
bridge like four inches
from the water?
This is fantastic.
(slow folk music)
(boat horn blowing)
(dramatic folk music)
(screaming)
(laughing)
It goes up!
That's ama- whoa!
Thank you big blue!
Let's go!
(upbeat rock music)
We can see it, there it is!
New Orleans, you dirty
little bitch, I love you!
(upbeat rock music)
We're here!
New Orleans, the
city of dirty dreams!
(laughing)
(upbeat rock music)
We did it!
I jet skiied from
Chicago to New Orleans!
(people cheering)
- [Kristen] You did it!
- And there's Kristen!
- You made it!
(crowd cheering)
I'm outta gas!
- You can do it, come on!
You're almost there.
- And then I pull up,
and as a prank to me,
the Marine team had rigged it
so that as I'm about
50 feet from the dock,
my engine dies, and I think
that I've run out of gas.
(laughing)
What a funny prank!
No!
- Get your butt over here!
- What do you want me to
do, I don't have any gas!
- You're not giving up!
- I'm giving up!
- You did not go for seven
days slapping your balls
against a seat making
you sterile for nothing!
(crowd cheering)
(band playing)
♪ When it's only been a week
♪ But it feels like a year
(slow, dramatic piano music)
♪ I'm coming home
♪ Taking the next train
♪ Boarding the next plane
♪ I'm coming home
♪ Getting out of this place
♪ Coming home
♪ So I'm coming home
♪ Taking the next train
♪ I'm coming home
♪ Boarding the next plane
♪ Knowing you can't keep me away
♪ I'm coming home
♪ Coming home
♪ Sun is up
(crowd cheering)
- [Announcer] Now give it
up for Kurt Braunohler!
(audience cheering)
- Hi New Orleans!
I just jet skiied from
Chicago to right fucking here!
(audience cheering)
Oh, guys, so I jumped
in this fucking river,
right here.
(crowd gasping)
Right, yes, I did.
Right out in front
of Cafe Du Monde,
I jumped in the river, I
towed my jet ski myself
to this landing to get here,
to give a show to
you fucking people.
(crowd cheering)
Put your hands together,
welcome to the stage,
Kristen Schaal!
(crowd cheering)
- I thought for half a second
that you all were giving
Kurt a standing ovation.
And I was like, "I don't know."
(audience laughing)
No, it's beautiful, I
can just see it now,
in Africa, you know,
years from now,
there's gonna be
a dad and his son,
his little son's gonna
be petting that goat.
And he's gonna just look down
at his son, gonna be like,
"A jackass got you that goat.
(audience laughing)
"A real dipshit."
Thanks, Kurt.
- Fuck yeah!
Are you guys read to be
a part of Roustabout?
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat jazz music)
Let's go up to
Second Line, come on!
(cheering)
(upbeat jazz music)
So here's the deal.
This show is all about
inserting absurdity
in the world and make
strangers' lives better.
And we did it, we
actually did it.
(slow, dramatic music)
Made it all the way from
Chicago to New Orleans.
Had some adventures.
Made some friends.
Lost some friends.
But I still haven't
raised $50,000.
And I can't rest until I do.
Yeah!
Woo!
Well, I guess the
adventure continues.
Roustabout.
(slow dramatic music)
(intense electronic music)
Goddammit guys, I made
it to New Orleans,
but I didn't make it to my goal.
That's okay, because
you can still help.
Donate to Heffer right now.
Click on this link,
give em some money.
Make the world a better place.
Thanks for watching Roustabout.